a couple of weeks ago I told you about
how Facebook Twitter Google lots of
online platforms were pretty
successfully used for the purposes of
Russian propaganda in order to influence
the American presidential election of
2016 and I recently suggested that the
reason we haven't heard much from some
of those online networks about exactly
how this happened isn't because they
support Russia or support Trump or
anything along those lines but rather
because they really want to keep secret
just how much power they have over
influencing public opinion through their
algorithms and technology and there's
another reason that a couple of viewers
sent in to me which is a lot of these
companies that are viewer said don't
have that much control because they have
very few employees actually doing
quality control and monitoring what is
being advertised and I thought that that
was a really pretty interesting point
we've now learned over the last 24 hours
that Twitter really really really wanted
Russian state media station RT RT
America more specifically to spend a ton
of money on Twitter's election related
ad inventory and specifically we've now
learned that Twitter offered RT America
15% of all American election related ads
for 3 million dollars now that's
interesting for a few reasons number one
three million dollars for 15% of all of
Twitter's u.s. election ad inventory
seems shockingly cheap because it
implies that all Twitter election ads
were worth 20 million dollars which is
odd for a company whose market cap is
over 15 billion dollars so that's one
thing that's kind of weird but not what
I want to focus on at the time of these
leaked emails that show Twitter offering
their ad inventory to Artie Artie was
buying at the time 2 percent of all US
election related ads on Twitter and
Twitter offered to bump it up to 15
percent which is more than 7 times their
previous ad buy and to get it out of the
way no one is disputing the validity of
these leaked emails right Twitter said
well we don't discuss conversations with
possible or current advertisers but
nobody is denying the authenticity of
these leaked emails so why is this a big
right like why do we care why is it
important that Twitter can sell ads to
whoever they want why would we want to
bother with that a couple different
reasons no one is disputing Twitter's
right to sell ads to whoever they want
presuming that there's no other laws
that are being violated by those ad
sales the part where it gets interesting
is that just last week Twitter said
they're going to be banning all RT
related accounts from advertising on
Twitter a sort of proactive
organizational ban now why did Twitter
do that they said this decision was
based on the retrospective work we've
been doing around the 2016 election and
the US intelligence community's
conclusion that both RT and Sputnik
attempted to interfere with the election
on the behalf of the Russian government
the intelligence report in which Twitter
which Twitter reference called
RT the Kremlin's principle International
propaganda outlet so we need to cut
through the BS on this and very very
quickly there are people saying that it
was wrong for Twitter to ever offer ads
to RT and there are other people saying
it's wrong that now Twitter is banning
RT because it's a limitation on free
speech or censorship or something along
those lines
it's neither in a sense Twitter's
actions have actually been totally
consistent with the financial motive
before Twitter thought the best move is
let's try to get some Russian state
money they seem to want to buy election
ads let's try to get them to spend as
much money as possible on Twitter now
they thought let's try to clean up our
reputation by loudly saying we're not
going to allow RT to buy ads at all it's
the same thing in that sense twitter is
being completely consistent here it's
not about it being moral or immoral in
terms of the decision or action by
Twitter it is a moral it is unconcerned
with the rightness or wrongness it's all
about money PR and optics now that being
said it would still be interesting to
talk to people at Twitter and say what
made you think it was a good idea to
volunteer 15% of your election ad
inventory to the state media of a
foreign hostile nation I always talk
about this epistemology question that's
good to ask how did you come to that
belief how did you come to that
conclusion I would love to say that to
some of
the Twitter ad sales team or whoever was
involved in this decision
people are also by the way and I'm
curious about this some people are
reporting to me that they're tweeting
about this story and that their tweets
are being deleted and a lot of times
when people say that this is going on
its total user error like they didn't
have an internet connection when they
posted the tweet and it never actually
got posted but if you have any
information on Twitter deleting posts
about this story I'd be interested in
hearing about that the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad